you need to write down what's with the
jeans hi I'm Kim an and I'm here to film
that this is such a beautiful Villa
Rossini
with the first time of my ever
experienced in my life
with two young men memory and the first
time big hard cock now what Kim and
we're used to having a very safe for
work version of Kim an where she doesn't
say the naughtiest things you know with
two gentlemen
especially what is amazed is I was able
to take a really really hard long piece
into my vagina as well as would you call
that
[Music]
what you'll call that rectum and you
thought oh this poor Thai lady doesn't
even know it she doesn't know what
they're about to do to her
yeah she's like you're sweet grandma
like you say hi grandma
you're sweet Thai grandma how do you say
I don't know their words man I'm just so
innocent I don't know what form I had
you go back down dead to me but then we
are today we learned that she knows it
turns out she does know some of those no
I don't like him in this is not the key
man I know it's not the command that we
grew up with yeah you know in my house
we had Kim in on every day night and day
and she always made it fun and and
friendly for people of all ages Kimmy
and now came a her diction is ridiculous
I am at a villa about to film I like I
should film like it's a oh yeah she's
like there are many artifacts here Mitch
no one cares artifacts like the people
are listening they're like oh yeah
exactly like the audience is
Architectural Digest yeah uh-huh I study
hard to my voice in your conversation
for nearly free I know oh yeah that way
you know keep yeah rekt I'm not and I
don't like that she's not referring to
gentlemen anymore
there is so many adventure within me
doing this past 10 months this past 10
months 10 months that's interesting it
must be went the time that she started
doing this stuff this horrific
pornography about the time she ran out
of money yeah
what made you I think I really think she
did it for the adventure I really do
Oh bullshit I think Kim man was like you
know what I'm 60 something I look good
you know she looks really good yeah
her body is amazed what is amazed to
calling it yeah asshole she says it so
gingerly asshole no don't say it like
Kim Jong Il yes he does
no Kim I am his mom like these that's
true
she has a villa with two gentlemen I
will say in her asshole
[Music]
asshole
let's see what else you shoot whispers
so you get that what is amazing
gentlemen and penis and rectum yeah
she's like there's two cocks really
quaint place and it's really really
comfortable
oh good with a lot of artifacts you try
the house as well as outside fascinating
I feel really really comfortable of
being outside you put those artifacts in
especially with the two gentlemen are
still there
really treat me very special today
that's one way of putting it that
special to really get them to be really
really hot and I feel that me Kym Illman
your mom have a lot to offer
yeah even though it's my first time at
bitch though I say I'm a bit shaky what
yet I know it's shaking well nervous and
I feel really satisfied satisfied is
fine stuff to my this is my first time
and I'm truly satisfied with my whole
body being caressed kissed and save
beautiful words know their touch mm-hmm
I feel very very excited if you heard
this description you would think it's
the sweetest lovemaking session and it
is a pig out pounding what's its
standard porn like there's nothing yeah
this and y'all two dudes on a girl porn
mop mop mop back and forth yeah like she
gets turned the fuck out with by Obama
mr. white folks this is really
unexpected it's really honest to be so
happy oh my god internally and I got
really around so I'm gonna throw up
and because entirely the physical end of
it I feel that they have really really
big cock nine and a half inches and plus
fries that is not what she said she did
not say Emprise no she did not
yes that is terrible what do you mean
you told me she did not say no listen
I'm not a hate monger right I don't mean
to you know that's I just I know what I
hear and that's just what I heard I
expect to have such a beautiful
experience dressing it up like it was
her year abroad and she was like you
know I had my I was painted bringing a
rose garden by this artist and I never
thought I would liberate myself in such
a way to allow myself to be painted nude
yeah she got double fucking blowing out
air tight yeah she's just DP'd by a
couple of pigs they've got on the street
which is interesting that she really
romanticizes this whole thing she's in a
villa yeah she was bitch really knows
how to talk herself into sin yes I was
so hot for them especially on the scene
that they put their hard cock into my
asshole I was so ready to come I'm just
trying to hold my pleasure
yeah what hold my hand I'm just thrilled
to be in the scene to to have them next
to me their body is such perfect I look
around
it seems like no one heard me and as I
go on towards the end I seem to be
really local local she did say woke oh I
am so excited internally
right now after the scene my whole body
is seems to be still vibrant my whole
body is shaking you know it's so weird
that I have them so oddly turned on that
wasn't expecting that I think the same
way that he wasn't expecting these two
guys to you know enjoy her so much I
wasn't expecting to be so keyed into
what you say around are you one of the
gentlemen I'm one of the gentlemen you
think come in I would get along yeah you
do uh you know what what I do like about
command is that she seems so sincere
yeah she really does enjoy express
really yeah a bit of a time this yet I
have to say of all the porn stars I
think she's the most articulate I've
ever ever heard you know she can convey
feelings yeah and my body all over I
feel it's weird she doesn't know most of
the time in a sexual sense people don't
go like yeah my asshole nobody say ass
put it in my ass it's like the Caucasian
so you know we does call it or a
butthole you want to go to but put it
I'll put it in my bottle yeah I know you
say I like it up the butt right yeah in
my inner leg I like ass play-by-play
no one says oh she's a real she's in hey
hey can we find Kim Ann there listen
she's accessible yeah I'm sure she's in
LA we gotta find can do important does
anyone know how to get ahold of Kim I do
a command to come over yeah well we're
just call her I think we should we
should interview Kim aye are you making
fun and she doesn't it's not as Lavery
like No
Kim Hyon was more of a gentle spirit
she's supposed to cheese I do think
she's educated yeah yeah this is why I
believe that this is an adventure for
her I really believe she is in her 60s
yeah and she goes you know what I'm
gonna do this totally crazy sexual thing
where I think it reaffirms to her how
attractive she is that she gets the
praise like she probably as an
attractive woman was sexually sought
after her whole life right is in her 60s
it starts to begin a decline she does
sex on video gets live attention that
sees comments eggs I think you're right
I think you're right still very sexually
because she's very body conscious you
can see she works out she does care of
herself got the big fake he's on yeah
she's yeah so that you're right I think
I think you might be on to something
there Tom that's why you should give her
and she has two degrees remember I have
two degrees what one something important
yeah when I say guys I might say one-way
ticket from Thailand